[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur salis
world heute gibt es eine resteverwertung
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr sie auch die
weihnachtsfeste und obwohl wir
weihnachten nicht feiern haben wir immer
weihnachtsfeste schoko nikoläuse lollis
oder auch nach ostern haben wir immer
diese reste und heute möchte ich die
typische resteverwertung machen und
zeigt euch ein richtig cooles rezept
dazu heute machen wir cupcakes eine
kleine resteverwertung die cupcakes das
ist natürlich jetzt nur eine idee ihr
könnt daraus natürlich auch alles andere
zu bereiten ich habe jetzt hier
spekulatius marzipan und schokolade und
wähle die cupcakes zaubern
die habe ich jetzt einmal die zutaten
das sind die grundzutaten und dann könnt
ihr alles dazu nehmen was ihr an resten
zu hause habt keiner sein dass sie
andere habt die grundzutaten sind 300
gramm zucker eine prise salz 140 gramm
etwas butter milch 200 gramm mehl und
viertel teelöffel natron einen halben
teelöffel backpulver und etwas man will
extrakt also ich nehme jetzt hier an
resten die spekulatius kekse ich nehme
marzipans und schokolade
die werden jetzt einfach alle
zerkleinert
[Musik]
dazu kam direkt hinterher klappt auch
gut und dann nehme ich noch ein paar
chocolat ließ natürlich den neulich
schon vorher entfernen
[Musik]
das habe ich die restliche alle drin und
jetzt kommen einfach noch die übrigen
muffin zutaten rein salz zucker die eier
dann das öl er vermische ich jetzt mehl
backpulver natron und natron sorgt dann
wirklich dafür das thema finde es
nochmal schöner aufgehen natron brauchen
wir auch ein bischen säure
daher empfehle ich da immer buttermilch
ein wenig einer buttermilch habt so wie
ich jetzt auch gerade neben dir einfach
normale bild und dann einfach ein schuss
zitronensaft
[Musik]
man kann natürlich auch der zins
präsident habe so geht's
[Musik]
und wenn ihr merkt ob das ein bisschen
zu festigen da einfach noch ein bisschen
buttermilch oder mädels da kommt einfach
darauf an wie viele reste dazu gibt wie
viele trockenen
jetzt einfach mit einem 1 portionierer
zum beispiel die mafia form befüllen
[Musik]
können die machen schon gebacken werden
und nicht stellen derzeit schon mal die
schokolade her
gbc die sahne in den topf von lasso
aufkochen und kann in der zwischenzeit
dann schon mal die schoko reste
zerkleinern
doch lieber nikolaus die werden leckere
cupcakes kann man fast schon so
verdrücken aber manchmal gibt es das
schokoladen sorten die sind einfach ein
bisschen dicker mann ist besser wenn man
sich reibt oder klein hat
gebe ich die heiße sonne über die
zerkleinerte schokolade und wenn sie
zerkleinert ist dann wird es ja auch
ganz ganz schnell flüssig ich habe jetzt
auch hier nicht die komplette saga auch
geguckt denn ich will ja auch noch die
sache gleich wieder schnell
herunterkühlt daher nur um zahlen teilt
das dann wenn die schokolade komplett
geschmolzen ist haben die restliche
sahne dazu dann kühlt so auch schon mal
runter und jetzt endlich die sahne in
den kühlschrank damit wir wieder
kühlschranktemperatur annimmt und kann
dann entweder die creme zubereitet
[Applaus]
und wer denn jetzt noch alles abkühlt
kann ich auch schon mal die deko
herstellen dafür werde ich jetzt
provokant herstellen und habe jetzt ihr
zucker und gestiftete mandeln und ich
nehmen da noch spekulation es für die
deko den zucker gebe ich jetzt hier in
eine pfanne und las ihnen
karamellisieren
und dann kommen gleich dem wandel stücke
im zucker immer schön aufpassen ich
hatte den herd erst auf höchster stufe
und dann habe ich ihn runter gestellt
damit der zucker nicht verbrennt geht
nämlich ziemlich schnell karamellisieren
hier noch die restlichen stücke und die
heute noch ein bisschen runter
jetzt gebe ich den mandeln dazu jetzt
einfach noch so ein bisschen mitrösten
caramelle so ein bisschen gefährlich
denn man hört kein zwischen kein
rauschen aber das echt extrem heiß das
macht mir immer ein bisschen anders da
[Musik]
dann wenn es lecker nach wandeln und
nach karamell duftet nämlich aus der
pfanne heraus und dann direkt zum
abkühlen am besten auf dem backpapier
oder zum beispiel auf einer dauer backe
folie
das werkzeug und die pfanne bekommt er
wieder sauber mit wasser also hier
einfach in die pfanne ein bisschen
wasser geben aufkochen lassen und dann
löst sich die karamell schlicht und ihr
können die panisch in sachen hier hat
sich jetzt die mandeln schön abkühlt am
besten nicht anfassen weil sie wirklich
sehr sehr heiß sind und wenn gleich
alles abgekühlt ist können wir die
cupcakes zusammensetzen
[Musik]
die sache ist jetzt richtig schön
abgekühlt da kommt jetzt noch ein
bisschen quark dazu stark macht die
creme so ein bisschen leichter und jetzt
einfach mit seiner partei zu schlagen
und da ist wirklich ganz ganz wichtig
dass die sahne creme wirklich wieder
kühlschranktemperatur hat also lieber
ein bisschen länger drin lassen oder
kurz noch ins gefrierfach stellen damit
sie einfach jetzt nicht gerinnt beim
aufschlagen
[Musik]
habe ich einen spritzbeutel mit einer
großen stern de da kommt jetzt die creme
rein
[Musik]
und dann einfach die cupcakes damit
bespritzen wenn die schmecken so schon
richtig gut hier freunde und probiert
aber mit der creme finde ich sie zum
ausbildungs dieses kleine örtchen
[Musik]
was machst du da bist in werther aha
sofort gesehen nicht natürlich veräppeln
ja ich bin auch spekulativ sich ich bin
eben auch richtig fan davon wenn es im
sommer 35 grad ist und ich gegen den
vorratsschrank und merck noch ist eine
spekulation resteessen ja weil ich
glaube das hat jeder so spekulatius
marzipan nikolaus genial ist ich meine
des lenkers was überhaupt ist warme
milch mit spekulatius das nicht das ist
ja wahnsinn wirklich warm ich neben
klassik sie rein und wenn ich den löffel
geben ist okay ich jetzt gern morgens
machen
doch gerne tyrannosaurus rex oder in der
küche und haut das ding rein meine
cupcakes da gibt's ja auch so methoden
wie man die ist und wie man so nicht
dass hier das ist elegant mit ich glaub
ich mach dir nichts draus machen ihren
zweiten lassen
[Musik]
und super ist gut zum nachmachen
empfohlen
auf jeden fall mit einer botschaft nicht
gut ja es sind ja weihnachtsfeste ich
meine spieler zu jeder zeit drin
man kann ja die spekulation ist krieg
zum weglassen oder einfach nur die
nikoläuse verbrauchen auch für die
nikoläuse da kann er vielleicht aus dem
teig zum google luft machen und dann die
schokoladen oktober gießen gleich gut
ich glaube es gibt keinen menschen auf
der welt der im januar nicht nur
weihnachtsmänner irgendwann schon
dadurch auch und nach ostern hat man
auch osterhasen und deswegen ja könnte
das gerne mal ausprobieren
ihr könnt mehr schreiben welche
typischen reste ihr nach weihnachten
oder nach ostern oder war noch immer zu
hause übrig habt denn dann kann unser
gemeinsam vielleicht nochmal rezepte
überlegen und wenn ihr wollt dass ich
öfter mal mit resten backe oder koche
dann schreibt einfach ihr könnt ja
wirklich einfach mal schreiben das sind
meine typischen reste in meinem back
oder krank und dann überlegen wir uns
einfach immer rezepte dazu muss nicht
immer süß sein können auch keine ahnung
grease oder polenta und dank gibt es
einen riesen trend nach den ganzen
jahrzehnten ja wir jetzt zwei minuten es
gibt ein riesen trend und zwar ich weiß
dass jamie olivers gemacht ich weiß
nicht ob es stimmt nicht stimmt und zwar
sammelt der von alten und restaurants
sachen einige übrig geblieben sind und
macht damit neue sachen damit nicht
weggeschmissen werden diesen trend wird
auch momentan in berlin glaubt gemacht
dass nur im interesse aller werte und
ganzes restaurant betreibt
bin ich zwar nicht direkt vom teller
zeug meiner nicht direkt vom teller
sondern einfach sachen die
weggeschmissen
okay finde ich auch cool hier also
schreibt gerne in die kommentare und der
mauer öfter resteverwertung genau
danke fürs probe kost den nehm ich kann
ich doch ich habe grade besucht da kann
ich da mit dem springs gleichsam und
dekorieren alles darauf macht's gut
macht's besser
[Musik]